I've discovered a dead something in the
middle of the field and it now for the
first time has become real that we're
about to kill birds
[Music]
we're here at GaN straw farms we raise
approximately ten thousand Birds give or
take that you get such a great reaction
out of people after they consume
something that you spent so much effort
raising and keeping safe I hope we can
enlighten some folks on the process of
actually killing your own food I love
animals man is all cats I'm not someone
who necessarily kills things
who knows maybe I'll be a vegetarian
tomorrow or something I don't want to do
this but I think it'll be a good
educational experience I want to know am
i okay with this
[Music]
these guys are like 10 weeks old and we
do multi-age farming we could these are
ones that we could kill any know you I
mean if you wanted a Cornish handle
instead of kill will call harvest them
harvest feels better yeah it does it
it's all part of that gentling is
something i do because like you owe me
money or are you suing my family yeah
yeah I have a I have a blood debt to
settle this is like this is I got to eat
I'll take you inside that little plastic
thing there those are actually five days
old okay
these are for your shoes put those on
it's a little biosecurity
[Music]
[Music]
it kind of smells strong like hair dye
walk with your feet close to the ground
they will not they will not hurt you I
have to actually derma duckling he's
that kind of look like this feels really
weird to pick something that you know
you're going to tell is this arbitrary
I'm just like yeah you know
[Music]
[Music]
chosen fatty okay we're gonna go put
them in the cage
take them up to the harvest station and
do the deed
[Music]
I took my rings off like I would for a
bar fight this will be the final stage
for the bird as far as him being around
we're gonna place him in the cone upside
down where my parents are from and I'll
solve it a baby like the same thing with
a hanging upside down and they like slit
the throat and that's kind of like the
way of the land like but you know it's
still really sad
[Music]
what's the shame is it when we die we
won't become some tasty meal thank you
at least their death is serving a
greater purpose you don't want to cut
through feather but you just find a spot
you do this side and then you do the
same thing this side you'll feel the
blood rush down your hand and that's
when you know you did it right
all right about that yeah there see ya
let go
[Music]
there's a hozeva the chicken is already
gone as we're talking right now she's
gone we don't need to watch
if you like my response to these kind of
things is to just to numb myself
emotionally and not really allow myself
to feel is that what robots say so weird
the instinct to be like it's okay buddy
it's okay buddy
it's hot keep going hold on to the legs
and go all the way in it only takes a
few seconds
I don't like then when the chicken is
done morning next time warning up and in
[Music]
because we're city folks we brought
Trader Joe's barbecue solid isn't it
super weird that that was the chicken
that we picked out of the house like a
couple hours ago thank you for anything
keep an you're doing great this chicken
is delicious it tastes fresher maybe
because I saw it die don't take your
food for granted understand what it
takes to get it on your plate I don't
know that I'm gonna leave here like
vegetarian or vegan but I definitely am
gonna like think about it more right so
cute little compared to y'all
it feels weird to smile during